but we're gonna begin with this as you
wake up in the West President Trump says
the military was quote in his words
cocked and loaded to carry out
airstrikes against Iran overnight when
he suddenly decided not to do it this
morning Iranian state TV broadcast what
it claimed are the first remnants of the
American surveillance drone they shot
down the US says the aircraft with a
wingspan bigger than a 737 was flying
over international waters Iran says it
has quote indisputable evidence that the
drone entered Iran's airspace the
president said he called off retaliatory
strikes because the estimated death toll
of a hundred and fifty people was too
high
David Martin at the Pentagon what do we
know about this planned attack good
morning
the president's tweet describes what
would have been a very limited strike
against just three sites that were
involved in the shoot down of the
American drone it was a go one official
said and then it wasn't another official
said simply cold feet the stand down
came 24 hours after this an Iranian
missile knocking an American drone out
of the sky sending it corkscrewing down
into the ocean the shoot-down was
celebrated on Iranian state television
with a video purportedly showing the
missile on its way to the target but
President Trump seemed inclined to write
it off as just an accident I find it
hard to believe it was intentional if
you want to know the truth I think that
it could have been somebody who was
loose and stupid that did it that didn't
sound right to CBS News analyst and
retired Admiral sandy Winnefeld I don't
think it was a rogue attack I think it
was premeditated and I do think it was a
great mistake on Iran's part when asked
about retaliatory strikes the president
was non-committal you'll find out you'll
find out but at an afternoon briefing
Democratic congressional leaders warned
the president of the unintended
consequences of even a limited strike
the president may not intend to go to
war here but we're worried that he and
the administration may bumble into a war
the US military spent much of the day
declassifying intelligence to show the
110 million dollar surveillance drone
had not violated Iranian airspace as
iran's Foreign Minister claimed it had
the u.s. called it an unprovoked attack
which raised the question would the u.s.
be seen as weak if it did not retaliate
against an attack on one of its aircraft
administration is going to have to
respond to this or lose a lot of
credibility and standing in the region
and around the rest of the world
Republicans like Senator Lindsey Graham
agree Iran cannot be allowed to attack a
US aircraft without paying a price and
Secretary of State to pop out is
expected to visit Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates to discuss what the
US should do next
Anthony David thank you